[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
chapter review for attack on Titan
chapter 99 has just become available so
we're gonna be talking about it right
now
this was another jam-packed chapter
insane twists and turns
Willy Tiber reveals a stunning secret to
everyone in Marley but is he telling the
whole story
I think Willy is still hiding something
important but more on that later also
Aaron's secret plant seems to be coming
together in a dramatic way but what is
he actually planning to do and what
about Zeke is Zeke in on the plan and
working with Aaron more clues suggest
that he might be by a guy's crazy
chapter and of course if you're not
caught up to the manga you have to know
that this will contain spoilers so
proceed with caution if you enjoyed
these chapter reviews that we do here at
anime up or be sure to smash that like
button to let us know if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you can be
notified every time a new review is
uploaded and also recently here on the
channel we started doing chapter reviews
for the my hero academia manga so if you
are a boku no hero fan be sure to check
that out in Chapter 99 we start off with
a brief flashback of anni Reiner and
Bertolt talking about the one man who
hung himself after telling them that he
was from a town where everyone else was
killed by the Titans
this was back when the three warriors
first infiltrated parodies and this
story has kept coming up in the past few
chapters and if you've been following my
reviews you know that I had speculated
that maybe Reiner killed this man and
made it look like an accident and I
thought this because it was way too
convenient that this man decided to kill
himself right after telling the Warriors
about his hometown and now the Warriors
could just say that they were from that
same hometown and no one could deny it
because everyone else was from there was
then during this flashback Bertold is
wondering why the man told him the story
before he hung himself and any things
that he wanted someone to forgive him
while bertolt thinks that he wanted
someone to judge him I'm not sure if
there is a
story that the man told them that we
still don't know or if they're just
talking about the story of how everyone
in his village was killed but I assume
that if this man had something to feel
guilty about then maybe he told him
something we don't know yet and I wonder
if this story whatever it is will come
into play later right after that we are
thrown back into the room where Aaron
and Reiner came face to face in the last
chapter after Falco brought Rainer
they're thinking that mr. Krueger was
just an old friend
at this point Falco still isn't aware
that anything is wrong as Aaron tells
Reiner to sit down Aaron also informs
Reiner that they are in a place where
they can hear what is happening on stage
and by the way they are right under a
building where a lot of people live and
we'll be watching the festival from
their windows Eden then shows Reiner
that he cut his hand basically telling
Reiner either sit or I will turn into a
Titan and kill all those people because
the building will collapse because of
this Reiner gives in and sits down we
then see Willy Tiber looking very
nervous as he gets ready to go onstage
and make his big speech but is he
nervous because he doesn't know how the
speech will go over or is he nervous
because he is still hiding something the
woman from Asia that we met in the
previous chapter and whose name is
Kiyomi wishes him luck and says that she
hopes that he finishes his role safely
which is an interesting choice of words
what role is Willy really plain what is
his true plan Kiyomi is then shown
leaving the festival with her security
detail as if she knows something is
about to happen that she doesn't want to
be around for next we see riders mom
saying hello to none other that Annie's
father mr leonhardt
Andy's dad says that this is the first
time he has seen riders mom since he and
someone else or multiple other people
came to meet her son
we learned that Berthold dad fell into a
coma and died and when rider's mom
suggests that Berthold gave everything
for Marlee just like Annie Annie's dad
says no Annie is still alive because she
promised him that she would come back an
interesting thing about Amy's dad in a
recent video where I talked about the
theories that are
and he could have royal blood I talked
about how the flashbacks we see of any
with her dad never appeared to be
happening in the internment zone and now
that we find out that Ryder's mom didn't
see any stat since he and someone else
first came to meet Reiner could me that
Annie's dad does not live in Lee Berio
if we assume that he first met Reiner
when Reiner was being considered for the
warrior program this could mean that
Annie's dad was working with the
government in some official capacity if
he as an ell daeun lives outside of the
internment zone and works for the
government in an official capacity it
could bag the theory that he may not be
a regular LDN but a member of the tiber
family or another noble family which
would make any unknowable as well the
next thing that we are clearly shown is
that all of the top leadership of the
military along with all the prominent
citizens of Marlay all the top
businessmen ambassadors from other
countries and the media are gathered
right there in one spot when I saw this
I couldn't help but think to myself if
you wanted to destroy Marlay what better
way than to bring the whole leadership
of the nation into this one place and
then just eliminate them all at the same
time I don't know if edit has it in him
to be that ruthless but if his plan is
to kill all the influential people who
have gathered here it would be
definitely the most effective way to
destroy Marlay then we see an
unidentified solider show up and tell
the Warriors of Marlay that they have
been summoned by general McGrath we
don't see the soldiers face clearly we
just see that he has some beard stubble
back in the underground room Reiner asks
Aaron why he came here
and Aaron tells him that he came for the
same reason as Reiner and that he can't
help it I assume that Aaron means that
he came here for the same reason that
Reiner had come to paradise both of them
want to save their people but of course
this puts them in direct opposition to
each other
Willie Tiber begins his speech in which
he talks about the great Titan war from
a century ago and how after brutally
destroying all their enemies the royal
families of the LDN empire that
possessed the titan shifter powers
turned on each
and continued fighting seemingly endless
wars as Willy is speaking the mysterious
soldier leads Zeke Porco and Peake to
supposedly meat Maga and here's a really
interesting detail this soldier tells
Zeke to use the front door but tells
Porco and Peake to follow him and go
another way
Peake tells the soldier that she has
seen him somewhere before but he simply
says that he is stationed at the west
rock club base but is here for extra
security the soldier leads Porco and
peek into a room that turns out to be a
trap and they fall through a trapdoor in
the floor and I can't help but think
that this mysterious soldier is either
an older Armand or possibly Connie also
in disguise just like Aaron peak would
have had the chance to see both Connie
and Armin during the return to shegaon
china arc so she may have recognized
them but wasn't sure from where it is
worth noting that in the manga Connie's
eyes are usually portrayed in a lighter
shade than Armand's and the eyes of this
soldier are closer to Armand's than to
Connie's so guys what do you think do
you think that this is Armand the new
Colossus Titan himself right here in
Marlay with the entire leadership of
Marlay waiting for him to stomp them all
out let me know down in the comments and
again I wonder why Zeke was told to go
another way why he wasn't lured into the
same trap is it because Zeke is in on
this secret plan is the theory that Zeke
and Aaron are working together true
we've known that Zeke was up to
something for a long time now and I
can't wait to see how this plan comes
together and what is Zeke's role in all
of it Willy continues his speech and he
makes a stunning revelation for everyone
to hear the Marlin hero Hallows did not
save the world from the war nor did the
Tiber family the true hero and Savior
was king carl fritz
king fritz felt bad for all the victims
of the Audion empire and he wanted to
end the war so he allied with the timers
and invented the story of the hero
hello's in reality king
fred's chose to leave for paradise in
order to stop the war and even though he
threatened the world with destruction if
they ever attacked the island his true
intentions were never to use the wall
Titans to destroy the world instead he
made a vow of pacifism and this vow was
passed on to every inheritor of the
founding Titan as long as they had royal
blood interestingly enough Willy also
says that LD ins and Titans should never
have existed to begin with which is a
strange thing to say and this makes me
think back to a theory video I made
about what the dinosaurs from the season
2 opening might have to do with ldiots
if my theory from that video is true
that what Willy is saying here would
make sense because the LD ins are not
like other human beings for a very
specific reason if you want to learn
more about that theory link to the video
is in the description of course everyone
in the crowd is shocked to learn that
the LD and king fritz was actually a
hero who saved Marley and that the LD
ends on paradise did not wish to harm
any of the Marlins but Willie says that
things have changed now that the
founding Titan Power has been taken away
from the royal family he says that the
name of the rebel who took the founding
Titan power and opposes the march
towards peace is Eren Jaeger and this is
where the chapter ends but right away
I'm struck by something clearly Willie
is not telling the whole story here
because if the audience on Paradise were
never a threat then why would Marley
send four warriors to try to take the
founding Titan power remember that when
the warriors first attacked and
destroyed wall Maria the founding Titan
was still in the hands of the royal
family it was only after this happened
that Grisha told the Fallen Titan power
from Frida Reis and gave it to Aaron so
what is Willie hiding why isn't he
telling the whole truth
why did Marley try to take the founding
Titan back if they knew that the king
behind the walls would not cause any
problems for them also remember all that
talk about the need for the founding
Titan to be inherited by someone with
royal blood how were the four warriors
supposed to take the founding Titan
power back
Majerle what if the plan was to have
Annie consumed the founding titan power
because she might actually have royal
blood we can't know for sure at this
time but I definitely feel that we are
building towards a big Annie reveal
especially with her father making such a
prominent appearance in this chapter and
we see that Aaron's secret plan is about
to unfold he has all the important
Marlins in one place
Reiner Porco and Peake have been taken
care of
Zeek deliberately spared from going into
the trap just crazy twists and turns and
I honestly can't wait for the next
chapter let me know what you think Aaron
is really planning what are Willy's true
intentions and where does Zeek come in
in all of this I'd love to hear your
thoughts down below
once again if you enjoy these reviews be
sure to smash that like button to let me
know if you are new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and click down
notification bell so you can be notified
every time one of these reviews is
uploaded as always thank you so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]